billions of people died in Attack on
Titan hundreds have been killed in Demon
Slayer but surprisingly only a mere 80
people have died in one piece and so in
this video we will explain every single
character that has been killed in the
story starting with the most
game-changing death in the story so far
the execution of the former pirate king
Goldie Roger isn't that right Gojo now
Roger was killed by these world
government executioners who can now
actually claim the title of killing the
strongest pirate to ever live however
this monumentous event occurred in the
very first page of the story after Roger
had already found the legendary island
called love tale but during his journey
he became deathly ill so he decided to
turn himself into the Marines he did so
in order to inspire the next generation
of pirates to find the legendary
treasure and change the world
huh
oh yeah of course this is by far the
only death in chapter one thanks kojo
and it's kind of crazy that the very
first chapter of one piece is also one
of the bloodiest because we also have
the death of the captain of the mountain
Bandits now after he kidnapped Luffy
like this and clashed with Shanks he
took Luffy out to see where he was then
eaten by a giant sea monster and
interestingly enough this is actually
the only time we've seen a named
character in one piece being killed by a
vicious sea creature yeah it is kind of
weird because the world is filled with
these massive monsters but even before
this this random Mountain Bandit was
also shot in the head by shanks's
crewmate's Lucky Roo and that's quite a
lot of action for just the very first
chapter of one piece and I'm not sure
about you but just seeing all that again
kind of makes you wish that you could
just relive watching the story of such
an amazing adventure unfold once again
right from the start or even better
imagine if there was an exciting game
based on it I mean if you were wondering
if such a thing exists Wonder no more
because this is raid call of the Arbiter
a limit it animated series produced by
today's great sponsor raid Shadow
Legends now I am sure that you've seen
enough people talk about the game itself
so you don't need me telling you again
why you should absolutely be playing it
right now instead look at the great
animation right here not bad am I right
now this is the very first episode of
the show which you can watch completely
for free in the game like this the
characters are actually really really
well written and the plot is incredible
as well now in general this series
massively is expanding the world of Rage
but not only that the game also gets a
ton of new features in celebration of
this show including new Champion bios
including both those from the show like
gallic but also other favorites like
death Knights and right now you can get
Art Attack One of the five new
characters from that show as a playable
legendary champion for free just by
logging into raid for 7 days between now
and July 24th which is doable come on
and if it's your first time playing use
my link in the description or this QR
code to get some insane bonuses we're
talking an epic Champion Knight errands
and more so I will see you for some real
action on the battlefield just like at
the beginning of One Piece however after
these initial three deaths in the very
first chapter we have to actually wait
almost two entire years until the next
death in the story that's until in
chapter 75 we meet the first of many
random unfortunate characters to simply
be in the wrong place at the wrong time
in one piece in this case this random
Marine Commodore who actually has the
hilarious name pudding pudding nice now
he's actually come to save nami's
Hometown from this ruthless group of
fishmen however arlong's henchmen sink
the marine Vessel before even landing on
the island and this sense pudding
pudding and his Marines to a early
watery grave maybe next time they should
wait until they're on land to actually
challenge a group of fishermen so do
make sure to keep watching to see all
the times that the straw hats actually
ended up killing people and in fact
Zorro is now on this list jumping ahead
a few more years and in chapter 190 we
learned that Zorro actually killed the
former Mr 7 the special agent working
for the Warlock crocodile sometime
before the story began apparently this
Mr 7 tried to forcefully recruit Zorro
into the organization but clearly it
didn't end that well but that's not even
the only one of crocodile subordinates
to be killed as Mr 11 was shot dead by a
supposed Ally Mr mellow in chapter 159
now staying in the Sandy ways of
alabaster these guys died by their own
hands while trying to take down the
warlord crocodile we're talking about
these guards right here and they
willingly drank this deadly hero water
and now you might ask why well it does
give you a ridiculous boost in strengths
but only lasting for a few minutes
before its effect turned deadly for its
user and their sacrifice just goes to
show how truly desperate they were to
take down the warlord and these are the
only official deaths in Alabaster
actually except for any of the random
characters who died in the massive
fighting during the Civil War looking at
you pal and this already leads us to the
absolute largest named character to die
in one piece which is this giant snake
kasigami which was worshiped by the
ancient people of Jaya however that all
changed when the snake God had its head
cut off by the Explorer Nolan in chapter
287. now Nolan did this to save this
woman here from being sacrificed and
while this event initially caused much
conflict eventually Nolan became great
friends with the tribe however maybe
this giant snake was actually some kind
of God because karma came back just a
while later to bite Nolan when he was
executed by his own kingdom now this was
because he couldn't find the famous city
of gold a second time but this was of
course not his fault since the Golden
City of shandora was literally shot into
the sky but don't tell that to this
greedy King right here instead we're
moving on from one slimy killer to
another so let's Jump Ahead to 6 volumes
to chapter
356. now during this chapter the
legendary shipwright Tom was taken away
and supposedly executed by spandom one
of the most hated characters in one
piece now this was all a setup after
spandom had used young Frankie's weapon
to frame Tom and so even though it
wasn't Tom's fault he accepted the
punishment to save his beloved
apprentices but yeah we really do hate
this guy so please Robin go ahead smack
him around a little bit more for us no
or another one or another one yeah
that's that's pretty good okay well in
fact we could wipe out spandom's whole
family the one piece world would
probably be a whole lot better off
because spandom's father spandyne was
the main government agent who brought
mass destruction to the scholarly island
of Ohara which on this channel we of
course take very personally while this
is clearly one of the saddest moments in
the story it is not nearly as
significant as the next death on this
list because this man right here is
called thatch the second division
commander of the Whitebeard Pirates or
at least he was until he founded the
darkness Logan devil fruit and was
instantly killed by Marshall D teach and
at this point Blackbeard who was also
part of whitebeard's crew had been
searching for this fruit for 26 years in
fact he only joined Whitebeard because
he thought that it was his best chance
at finding this one super rare and
special fruit so Blackbeard literally
stabbed thatch in the back and left the
Whitebeard pirates for goods and while
thatch himself is not super important
his death kicked off many of the most
important plot lines in the entire story
oh why you ask well because after
Blackbeard betrayed the crew a set out
to hunt down the traitor for revenge and
that all eventually of course led to
Ace's capture and the whole War at
Marine Forge plus this betrayal won
Blackbeard his famous devil fruit which
is super game changing because it is
literally the most mysterious power and
has helped him quickly become an emperor
of the sea himself which now already
takes us to throw LaBarge where we met
this zombie pirate named Captain John
and while he is already dead when we
meet him here wow that's kind of an odd
statement however moving on WE later
learned in a question Corner that this
former member of the Rocks Pirates was
actually killed by his own crew because
he refused to share his treasure and if
you think that any of these betrayals
are downright disgusting then make sure
to keep watching because it is nothing
compared to the next killers on this
list because in Saba ODI we meet these
inhumanly cruel world Nobles and in the
space of just three chapters we see how
truly awful these spacesuit wearing
Celestial dragons truly are they
needlessly kill not only one but two
innocent people as if they were just
being bugs and while we only see these
two particular deaths we can basically
assume that deaths like that are very
common for anyone unfortunate enough to
encounter the celestial dragons
seriously these dudes here are twisted
in all the worst ways however now
leaving behind Saba ODI our next death
is a really big one literally this
massive giant ORS Jr was a long time
friend of Ace who was taken out during
the world Marine Fort and while it was
never officially confirmed that he was
dead he had his whole leg sliced off by
doflamingo and he was bombarded by
attacks from countless Marines plus
we've never seen him again anywhere in
the story so I just assumed that he is
dead along with lots and lots and lots
of other random Marines and Pirates
during this Epic War but on top of that
of course marineford also gave us the
single most impactful death for Luffy in
the entire story and that's because the
whole point of the war at marineford was
to save Luffy's Blood Brother Ace who
was sentenced to execution by the World
Government after Blackbeard had turned
him in and while Luffy eventually did
free him the brothers could not escape
the wrath of the Marine Admiral Akainu
who gave us one of the most
soul-crushing moments in the entire
story like this moment broke Luffy both
physically and mentally and I can still
remember the deep sadness that I felt
seeing that moment for the very first
time and Luffy cannot process his
brother's death either and goes into
this mindless coma which almost costs
him his life and will to keep going
however eventually this loss makes him
realize that he was not strong enough to
protect his friends and not taking
things quite seriously enough also so he
decided to train for two years and
become a better captain and while this
war showed us some of the most insanely
overpowered fighters in the story none
of them compared to the single most
deadly force in all of One Piece that's
right I'm talking about stairs don't
believe me well just remember that these
stairs right here easily took out
Zorro's childhood friend kuina who
literally defeated Zorro
2001 times if that's not the definite
edition of a monstrous force of nature
then I do not know what is however an
easy way to protect yourself from the
deadly stair monster is by subscribing
to this channel I'm not sure if that
makes sense I guess it makes you stare
proof anyways after Blackbeard's
complete betrayal at marineford we get
another example of crew on crew violence
during the a Sabo and Luffy flashback
that's because this guy who's called
pochemy was killed by his own Captain
blue gem for failing to beat up a young
Ace and Sabo and speaking of bluejam I
don't know about you but I could really
go for my own Jam sandwich right now as
we get into the even deadlier second
half of the story because after the
two-year time skip and a month-long
break in real life we now move ahead to
Fishman Islands because that's where in
Chapter 623 the chattiest of all the
fishmen Fisher tiger was killed by
Marines for simply returning this Lost
Child to her home and that death meant
that Fishman continued to hate humans
for Generations however this hatred had
very serious consequences later on
because the human-hating fisherman holy
Jones actually assassinated the
fisherman Queen orokime because of her
ideals about humans and fishmens living
together in peace and soon after the
fisherman Queen's death we learned about
the death of the most mysterious
character in the entire story because
when Robin reads this pornoglyph at the
bottom of the ocean she learns about a
character named Joy boy as far as we can
tell this happily named figure was the
leader of the legendary ancient Kingdom
and while we do not know exactly what
happens we can assume that he was killed
during the final battle with the 20
kingdoms that ultimately formed the
world's government and while we've
learned a little bit more about joyboy
during the recent arcs which I covered
in depth in a previous video this is one
death that we absolutely will still have
to learn more about before the end of
the story on the other hand one
character that we certainly won't be
hearing from again is Virgo now this man
was posing as a marine while actually
working undercover for doflamingo
however after being stuck in the railing
of a laboratory by Trafalgar law Virgo
then died in a massive explosion that
rocked the entire laboratory on Punk
Hazard so congratulations you
food-loving man because you are the very
first name character to die in the new
world
congratulations however don't worry
Virgo was quickly joined by this snow
logia fruit user called Monet who was
seconds away from blowing up the entire
island with an even bigger explosion
unfortunately for her she was then
killed when Caesar Clown stabbed her
heart by accident but still because
little did Caesar Clown know that law
had actually tricked him and so he
actually killed his own subordinates
instead of the Marine Admiral smoker but
as hard as it is to watch someone
accidentally kill their friend it is
nothing compared to the tear-jerking
sickening sadness of loss flashback I
mean first we learned that basically
lost entire home Islands including la
sister Lami were wiped out by
neighboring countries because of a
misunderstanding about their disease and
then on top of that during chapter 767
this evil young doflamingo became so
disgusted by his own father for taking
away their status as Celestial dragons
so young dolphy shoots doflamingo homing
himself while his brother cries in his
father's arms holy damn what a horrible
little monster young dolphy already was
and in the very same chapter we get the
heartbreaking conclusion to Lost
flashback as well because here we see
doflamingo's brother Corazon steal the
opeopenomi to save love from his disease
and he stole his fruit from Diaz barrels
a pirate who wanted to sell the fruit to
the world government and this turned out
kind of poor for barrels I mean how
couldn't did with a name like that I
guess but of course no flamingo later
killed barrels because he did want the
fruit for himself and yet doflamingo was
not done yet with his Killing Spree
because in the safe chapter he then
executes his own brother Corazon and
this is honestly one of the saddest
moments in the story Corazon fights to
stay alive to height Law's frantic Cries
From doflamingo and he holds on just
enough to his life force for law being
able to escape now of course at least in
the end law does get his revenge during
the events of the dressrosa arc but
while doflamingo is our current leading
killer with three we jump ahead nearly
two years to whole cake Island where big
mom easily Takes the Cake as the
deadliest individual in one piece at
this point that's because we learn in a
flashback from chapter 850 that big mom
killed Zippo the brother of everyone's
favorite polar bear Beppo in that
chapter we learned that she stole his
entire lifespan as punishment for trying
to steal her Road Pony glyph and these
deaths just continued at the Tea Party
when katakuri killed this guy jigra for
attempting to break into the invitation
only party and then 10 chapter years
after those horrifying deaths we get one
of the most heroic sacrifices in the
story because as the strides are
attempting to escape from Big mom's
territory and her Army their ship is
trapped by perro Sparrow's sticky candy
so this leopard mink called Pedro
sacrifices himself by blowing up the
candy trap with a ton of dynamite and
while Pedro's Choice did allow the crew
to escape it was devastating for their
emotions police Oda don't ruin his
Sacrifice by bringing him back to life
like he sometimes likes to do and the
next death is one that Sanji would
probably be happy to hear and that's
because this lion looking guy who ate
the invisibility fruits that Sanji
really wanted up salon was killed by
someone from the Blackbeard Pirates but
it's not all good news for Sanji who
desperately wanted it because now shiriu
has already eaten that fruit and is
using it to Great effects which now
actually takes us all the way to wano
where we have the most named character
deaths of any Arc in the entire story so
far and it all starts off with this
smiling little man called yasuyi now he
was actually the former daimyo who
became the hero of the leftover town
until he was then caught stealing from
the flower capital and this set up his
execution in chapter 942 when he Reveals
His true identity and gives an inspiring
speech to the crowd that sends the
Shogun Orochi and his men into a frenzy
and they end up killing yasuya
immediately however the porcupine heard
men is not the only daimyo who meets
their ends during The wano Arc in fact
these three former diamonds called uzuki
tempura fugetsu um and zoro's great
uncle shimotsuki oshimaru were all
killed by kaido and his crew many years
before the start of the wano arc but of
course it's not just former Samurai on
kaido's Hit List because the emperor
even killed one or possibly two of his
allies this here is kuruzumi Higurashi
the previous user of the Clone fruit and
her partner kuruzumi simimaru who was
the the previous user of the barrier
fruit now it was confirmed in chapter
972 that kaido actually killed Higurashi
for interfering with his fight with
kozuki Odin and while we don't know for
sure we can assume that semimaru also
died around this time since we never see
him again but his devil fruit does pop
up again in chapter 972 is also the
spectacular climax of Odin's execution
now you might remember that he
heroically survived in a boiling pot of
hot oil for an entire hour and because
of his super impressive feat Odin's
retainers live to carry on his will now
unfortunately Odin himself was basically
dead at this point and kaido finished
the job with a bullet to the heads so in
case you're keeping track that's now six
for kaido and then just one chapter
later Odin's wife Toki delivered a
chilling prophecy that would go on to
haunt Orochi for 20 years however the
time fruit user was then shot and killed
by kaido's forces just as she finished
her Majestic speech I'm actually just
realizing that Oda really really loves
killing characters right after they say
like some epic sort of line worth it
though and this all takes us now to the
Epic conclusion of the battle on
onigashima but before we get there let's
go over some honorable mention Killers
who we still haven't yet discussed in
the story first we have poison which
actually wiped out Brooke's former
Captain Yorkie and his entire crew and
then disease also claimed the life of
senior Pink's child and wife gimlets and
Russian and of course it's at this point
I'd also like to mention Rock's disebec
now the former Fleet Admiral zengoku
tells us that this Legendary Pirate was
killed during the infamous Battle of God
Valley and while this may be true and
rocks could actually be dead I find it
entire possible that he may still be
alive somewhere in the one piece world
so we're not quite counting him here
however the greatest honorable mention
killer of all is of course Oda Sensei
himself the author who loves to kill a
particular group of characters quite
suspiciously and who might this group of
unfortunate characters be you ask well
pretty much anyone in a flashback well
yes but no not that one it's actually
mothers that's right there are almost no
significant mothers still alive in the
entire story and that's because Oda
thinks that if all the mothers were
still alive they would probably stop
their kids from becoming Pirates so as a
result Oda usually kills them off in
some tragic way that leaves a lasting
impression on their children for example
there was usab's mom bankina who died
from illness nami's adoptive mother
belmare who was killed by arlong Robin's
mom Nico Albia who died in the Flames of
Ohara sanji's mom in Smoke Sora who also
died from illness Port Gus D Rouge who
died from childbirth while carrying Ace
Rebecca's mom Scarlett who was also
killed by doflamingo's right-hand mem
Diamante and that's not even including
others that we've already mentioned like
otohime who was the mother of the
mermaid princess and Toki who gave birth
to Momo and hiori or Zorro's mother who
also died from illness though we've
never actually met her in the main story
but now let's dive right back into the
fiery conclusion of wano where in
Chapter 1008 we have the very first of
Odin's red Scabbard to meet their end
and that is Ashura doji who was a
mountain gang boss until Odin came and
tamed the wildlands of wano and after
the scabbards failed to defeat kaido
they were confronted by a twisted
version of their former Master Asura
doji realizes that this is actually
another clone created by their former
Ally kanjuro and with his very last act
he tackles the false Odin and together
they fall into a fiery explosion and
while we've seen characters survive
damage like this before it was later on
then confirmed that he actually did in
fact die here but speaking of conjuro
this traitor died in a very similar
place of glory after suffering many
fatal wounds when battling the red
Scabbard kinemon kanjiro crawled back to
roti's feet Orochi then ordered him to
create this massive blob of hateful
Flames to consume kaido's entire castle
and everyone in it and after creating it
conjuro collapsed and died however
luckily his master would also not
survive that much longer Mount Orochi
seemed to die many times during the raid
on onigashima like when kaido cut off
his head or when the Scabbard took out
many of his snakeheads however
annoyingly enough he always kind of
reappeared because of the special
abilities of his mythical Zone devil
fruit the Yamato no Orochi and that's
because his fruit allowed him to have
eight lives along with his eight
snake-like heads but by the time that we
see him in chapter 1048 he has already
had seven of his heads already taken out
and Orochi is then confronted by another
of the red scabbards denjiro and it is
fitting that dendro would be the one
that deals the final blow here because
he suffered for years secretly blotting
orochi's downfall for over 20 years but
with a last slash of his sword ninja
finally slays the Twisted Shogun
bringing Odin's Revenge after 20 long
years of suffering and so good riddance
to the probably most annoyingly voiced
character in an entire anime
unfortunately there isn't a complete
happy ending here for the scabbards
though now with ashra that doji already
dead the pistol-wielding easel is
battling against agents of the world
government zp0 agency and already
heavily damaged diesel clashes with this
guy right here one last time and the
pair deal fatal blows to each other just
like with Asura doji izo's death was
also later on confirmed leaving a
Bittersweet taste to the end of the war
but since their famous battle tries
tsunachi basically means that they will
give their all to achieve Victory I
think that they will consider it a
sacrifice worth the freedom of their
country after over 20 years of
Oppression under kaido but speaking of
the big Batman himself it brings us to
the climax of the world onigashima and
two more really important deaths of the
ark or um at least possible deaths you
see in chapter 1040 the tag team Duo of
Law and Captain Kidd fully unleash their
awakened devil fruit powers to defeat
big mom First lost silencing bubble
canceled out big mom's Soul powers and
then kids super overpowered railgun
forces the helpless big mom out of the
castle and into a massive hole and
unfortunately this pit leads directly
into a pool of volcanic lava deep
beneath the surface of wano and if
literal molten lava is not enough to
kill big mom then I truly do not know if
she can be killed at all in the story
but for now we are led to believe that
she is dead since much time has passed
and she still has not reappeared and the
same can be said for the strongest
creature in the world kaido as the truly
epic Clash Atop The skaldon comes to its
end kaido used his insanely massive fire
dragon form that towered over the island
itself and with this mind-boggling
massive punch he then crushed kaido all
the way down into the same underground
lava pool as big mom which led to a
giant volcanic eruption as Luffy was
declared the victor of the battle and
while this surely was a truly amazing
moment in the story we have to give the
same disclaimers for kaido's death as we
did for big moms because kaido might
have somehow survived this Titanic
explosion but for now we're meant to
believe that the two Emperors of the sea
are well and truly dead and so after
four years in the most deadly Arc to
date the story moved on to an even more
shocking death or should I say deaths
that anyone could imagine because first
in chapter 1054 it's confirmed that
nifatadi Cobra who's the father of Vivi
and the king of alabaster was killed
during the meeting of the world
government's rulers after he saw the
ruler of the world emu and this is a
truly game-changing death since it was
blamed on Luffy's Blood Brother Sabo and
while no one really believes that it was
Sabo it is still hugely important
because not only was Cobra secretly one
of Luffy's allies but he was also one of
the few actual quote unquote good kings
in the story and so if anyone was gonna
try to change the government for good it
was going to be him so with him dead
this means that we may be getting an
even more Sinister World Government than
we had so far in the story which then
leads us directly to the destruction of
an entire Island because in an
unthinkable Display of Power either the
five Elders or emu the secret ruler of
the world Unleashed this massive blast
of laser beams that took out the entire
Kingdom of lulucia this includes the
king and the princess and this event in
chapter 1060 brings to light the truly
terrifying powers of the world
government they simply decided that this
kingdom was going to be erased and this
mysterious weapon of Destruction was
able to make it a reality within seconds
now we do not know if this is a devil
fruit power or simply an ancient weapon
but either way this is destruction on a
scale way bigger than anything that we
have ever seen in the story which makes
me wonder if this is how God Valley was
also raised from the map which now takes
us to the ark called Egghead Island
where on the island we are actually
giving a genuine murder mystery for the
very first time in the story now this
mystery came to an epic conclusion in
chapter 1077 when Shaka the Vega Punk
satellite who represents logic was shot
in the head by the trader of eckat
Island and while we still don't truly
know if Shaka is actually dead the
trader who turned out to be York who is
the vegapunk satellite representing
greed certainly acted like he was out of
the picture for goods and then just two
chapters later we get the most
undeniably badass one shot KO in the
entire story courtesy of the yonko red
hair Shanks you see with Captain Kidd
pulling up on elbaf and about to take
out shanks's entire fleet Shanks then
decides to deliver a single Godly
conquerors hockey infused slash that
takes out kit and almost all of his crew
and right after this assault Was Then
followed up by an even more massive dual
sword Blast from the Giant's Dorian
bragi which then sent kid and his entire
crew sinking to the Bottom of the Sea
and while we don't know yet for sure
again if kid will survive this ordeal
the incredible hype around this feat
leads me to believe that he might
actually be dead for good here but as
devastating a blow as this was to kid
fans everywhere it is not the first time
that kid has been beaten down in fact
did you know that he was actually beaten
up by his very first lover or did you
know that Shang this might have been
born on God Valley well if you want to
know more about every single tragic epic
and heartwarming backstory in one piece
you can watch that video right here
thanks for watching and I see you in the
next one